- I heard Denzel called him
because y'all had worked together,
- Yeah.
- And kinda was trying
to help you get the role
'cause he loved you and believed in you.
- Yeah.
Do you think it's something
he said that was like,
"No, I'm gonna see how
much he really will work?"
- I don't know if that played into it,
it's possible.
- I don't know that anyone
has that, in this business.
Oh, Denzel called, and
like, Baz, and was like,
like, did he know Baz, like?
- [Austin] No they'd never met before.
- And he just like, Denzel
Washington calls, right?
- Yeah. I um, yeah.
- Oh, no, look at your teary eyes.
- Yeah, he's powerful.
He's been my hero for so long
and I went into that play going,
I'm not gonna try to be Denzel's friend.
I'd read Ethan Hawke talking about them
doing Training Day together.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And he talked about this as well
and so I went in there and I thought,
you know, I'm not, I'm
just gonna do my job,
and so I showed up the
first day of rehearsal,
I memorized the four hour play,
such an intense play, and we did it,
and at a certain point,
Denzel started seeing that
I was showing up earlier
than he was to get to the theater
so he'd show up a little bit earlier
and then I'd show up a little bit earlier,
- Challenge him.
- Eventually one day it was just he and I,
and he thought that he was
there before me and I came down,
I'd already been up in my dressing room,
and it is just the dark theater
and he's sitting on the stage by himself
and I came walking down and he goes,
"Oh, I thought, I thought
I'd beat you here,"
and I said, "No, I've been
here for like an hour,"
and he goes, you know,
- but nice try.
- "Come over, I got an idea for you,"
and he kind of took me under his wing
and started giving me
acting advice and, uh,
- Wow.
- That was really huge for me,
and then, he didn't tell me
he was gonna call Baz at all.
He'd never met Baz.
- That's so nice.
- So very sweet.
- I love that you, you made such an impact
on him that he did something like that.
- Very kind.
- That's very, very cool.